Henry VIII's favorite pastimes was a subtle balancing act between his powerful nephew
Charles V and the dashing Francis I. His other hobby was less subtle and caused many famous
heads to roll. That was the price of the king's disfavor. The despotic Henry always preferred
the direct method for ending arguments. In 1535, a great humanist, Thomas Moore, fell
victim. And then came Anne Boleyn. Her crime? He gave the king a baby girl, Elizabeth, instead
of a boy. In time, the stake gave way to the hatchet. Henry VIII's son, Edward, succeeded
him, followed in 1553 by his daughter, Mary Tudor, wife of Philip II, son of the Spanish
king. Mary, called Mary the Catholic, died in 1558, along with her father-in-law, Charles
V. Illegitimate half-sister, Elizabeth, acceded to the throne of the age of 25. She was known
as Elizabeth the Protestant. Catholic Spain was then at her most powerful, and Elizabeth
Ruth began plotting against her.
Elizabeth's 39 articles founded the Anglican religion in 1563.
A few years later, the Pope declared her a heretic and excommunicated her.
A toast to the health of Francis Drake, our host.
The Queen told me that the Spaniards have no more shame.
Would you like to dance?
Hawkins, dear cousin, her majesty has well spoken.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
How sullen that gentleman looks, my dear Drake.
You must be referring to that one.
He doesn't seem to be enjoying himself.
Thomas Darty, my good man. Why so sullen, friend?
He says he won't drink because it's not good for his health.
Come now, come now.
Here.
Oh, why not?
You help.
Drink up.
Pip, pip, eh?
Isn't that good?
To your health, my friends.
Drink up.
What a fellow.
Keep up the good work.
What do you think?
I don't really.
The naval victory at Lepanto in 1571 brought Spain to the zenith of her power.
In 1572, the Low Countries decreed a general insurrection against Philip II.
Elizabeth came to their aid.
These are the thieves that we arrested.
Thomas Doughty will settle this matter.
Do you prefer death by hanging or by drowning?
Well, trust for the matter.
Go on, jump.
No, no mercy, oh no no mercy, listen, what do you want? Please, to work, talk to you a little. Ouch, I'm going, I'm going. The year is 1577, an expedition led by Francis Drake has just left the port of Plymouth. The goal is to explore the southern coastline of the Americas, but so far no one really knows where the ships are headed. Eve, Eve, Eve, all right, let's get the sails. Bravo, well done, great, great, keep it up, bravo, bravo.
Don't die.
I'm in position.
Okay.
January 27, 1578.
The expedition set at the Cape Verde Islands.
We're last for sure.
Let's go home.
We've been sailing to nowhere.
Now's the time to head back home.
What do you say, man?
I'll see what he says.
Okay.
In position.
We got it.
We're under attack.
In position of rub.
And sirs, my name is Nona De Silva.
Pilot of that ship.
The one you have just captured.
If you don't, you'll be locked up.
It's me in command here.
You say?
Permit me.
I am Francis Drake, commander of the expedition.
I should like to ask you to share my table.
No!
Please not.
Leave me alone.
Take him to my cabin.
This then is my proposed opinion would be.
I intend to proceed in a southerly direction, round the Tierra del Fuego, and finally sail back towards the north.
What do you think?
Francis Drake took command of the Maria, the largest of the captured Portuguese vessels.
are behind trying to keep up with the expedition's other ships is the pelican the command of doughty
with the aid of you still don't think it's time to turn around sure you're hard to port huh i said
you the shit marlet unfounded scoundrels all i've got the feeling i'm gonna blow my stack you take
the hell make it quick me turn around for me right starboard to the right see where am i see the sun
moved oh be fine in no time hey i need a trim ah yes you do look superb that'll teach you to wait
your turn hey now here i see long trips lots and lots of them i'm just what you need take that tell
me what it does for you now it's my turn i'm the chief here into line hey you like everybody else
wait your turn oh which of you gentlemen's next it's been fractured this will take care of it
thanks next please yeah am i am i seeing things
you can blame on drake now if i were cheap we never would have wound up here
i was saying this man drake is a fool he'll lead us to our deaths i'm taking command of this
expedition now you hear me i'm the new commander
francis drake commander of this expedition in the name of her gracious majesty queen elizabeth
of england to declare thomas doughty guilty of mutiny i now ask the crew to pronounce its verdict
oh man is the fate of all traitors if only he'd listened the doe or hind replaced the pelican on
the repaired ship's prow the vessel was renamed the golden hind on august 20th 1518 the expedition
reached the straits of magellan but no sooner had the ships left the straits than a storm blew up
the likes of which no man had ever seen our friendship was blown southward as far as the 57th
parallel good day gentlemen finally the wind died down they were able to sail northward to
an island off the coast of south america they landed on november 25th other ships had vanished
look up there hold of these watch out what's going on what can they want hurry up men quick
Soon things changed for the better.
Our friends reached Valparaiso on December 5th, 1578.
A magnificent Spanish vessel, the Great Captain, happened to be anchored there.
It was quite a catch.
The Great Captain was carrying 25,000 pesos in gold.
No less than 4,000 gold ducats.
The treasure changed hands.
On February 13th, 1579, the Golden Hine docked at Calao, the seaport for Lima, Peru.
Sound the alarm.
The vessels, the Cacafuaga, loaded in the jungles with treasure, set sail a few days ago.
how can we follow her without a rousing suspicion seems to me we'll have to proceed in this way
someone had the bright idea of stringing along empty wine jugs behind the ship to slow her down
until nightfall englishman lower your sails or we'll scuttle you who are you to give the orders
port us instead if you dare it took six days to transfer the treasure then it was tied ahead for
home i suggest we proceed toward the west the pacific ocean and africa now let's try to make
it by going north going north folly i insist in that case i prefer to take my leave sir oh as you
please sir and farewell my friends good luck you'll surely need it yours i've prepared an infallible
plan for putting an end to the scoundrel from england drake in the name of spain i possess a
fleet of great size that would be perfect governor but the english are now much further north no you
are quite wrong senor according to my information the golden hind has gone south towards panama
Hear me well, senors. Go away, of course. Drake is now to the northwest of Mexico.
Wherever! We've got to capture that creep wherever he is. I want my gold!
I was wrong not to listen to good old Silver when he told me not to go this way.
I have decided that we shall reverse our direction.
And in May of 1579, near Vancouver Island, the ship changed course.
And it's south. The days grew warmer. And warmer, even hot, by the time my friends reached the coast of New Albion, the 17th of June.
In the name of Her Majesty the Queen of England, I take possession of this kingdom whose king and subjects freely resign their right and title to be known as Nova Albion, Francis Drake.
On July 23rd, Drake left New Albion, freshly founded, and headed west.
Two months later, he sighted the Ladrone Island, where natives tried to stone them.
November 3rd, Moluccas, where they embarked spices by the ton, and where the local sultan gave them a royal welcome.
Voyage went on.
More lookouts were posted to keep watch for dangerous coral reefs.
And on January 18, 1580, just south of the celibate...
The Lord can help us to leave this place.
On your knees and pray, brethren.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to help us bail out this fast.
Everything we can do without must go.
Heaven.
That gold.
Oh, that's what's weighing us down.
Go overboard.
Now it's not the question we haven't talked yet.
Overboard.
Go.
Last hour has come, my brethren.
We must now repent all of our sins and pray to the Lord.
After repairs, they pressed on.
March 12, Java.
June 15, the Cape of Good Hope.
July 22nd, Sierra Leone.
A month later, the Canary Islands.
Finally, on September 26th, 1580, Jolly Old England.
After two years, nine months, and 13 days, 59 survivors reached Plymouth.
The Queen!
Queen Elizabeth, accompanied by the French ambassador and other dignitaries, came on board the Golden Hind.
Your Majesty.
Arise, Sir Francis Drake.
In 1587, after 18 years in prison, the Catholic Mary Stewart was condemned for conspiracy and was beheaded.
Spain's fury knew no bounds.
Rooting for next expedition, all former sailors are welcome.
Why, sure, I'll go.
Thousands of Flemish clothiers fled the Inquisition
and established themselves in England, where their trade flourished.
Chimney, grandfather!
Well, the Archbishop of London died of it, my dear.
My friends, my friends, how good it is to see you.
We're going to war against Spain.
We've been turning him away. Just look there.
In April of 1587, Francis Drake sailed into Cadiz,
encountering a large fleet of Spanish warships.
warships. The English fired a deadly volley, while the Spanish volley fell short. No time,
Drake's men boarded the Spanish vessels. Spanish vessels were captured or destroyed. Goods and
treasure were loaded onto the English ships. They sailed for home, leaving desolation in their wake.
Spain's reply was not long in coming. On July 20th, 1588, the Invincible Armada arrived at Plymouth
ready for battle. Enemy warships are just outside the port as thick as flies. Well then, use a fly
whatever let me finish my game defeat of the armada told the death mill for spain's great
aspirations eight years later an english fleet took cadiz destroying the ships in her harbor
looting the city and then sailing off scot-free in england spirits were high and bonfires were lit
queen elizabeth was at the peak of her power in the same year 1596 francis drake died during a
caribbean expedition but life went on queen encouraged the efforts of a young writer by the
the name of Shakespeare, who was staging his new play Romeo and Juliet. In 1598, Philip
of Spain died a bitter and worn out man. It was the end of the century that had seen
da Vinci and Michelangelo, the first humanists, Copernicus, Protestantism, the exploration
of America, and Montaigne, Cervantes, and Shakespeare. Glorious Spain had finally bowed
to Elizabeth's England. At Elizabeth's death in 1603, James II, son of the beheaded Mary
steward acceded to the throne in 1608 champlain founded quebec city on september 6 1620 78 men
and 24 women left plymouth on board the mayflower they were to become the first white america